so what's going on YouTube my name is
Meho alright we're gonna learn about
react native what it is and what is used
basically we'll just take a look at that
in this tutorial only and just go over
through some basic building blocks like
doing basic stuffs like navigation and
all transitions then some API fetching
HTTP requests timers and all that stuff
which basically you would need to
actually create a working of functional
react native application and so let's
start from the first question what the
heck this react native is many of you
might know but some of you do not have
any idea who I just stumbled upon here
somehow on this channel and now are
watching this tutorial randomly so for
you guys what react native is is that
it's a way to write cross-platform
applications on JavaScript so if you
know JavaScript then probably you can
get started at react native immediately
because what react native does is that
it provides you a way to write
JavaScript and then react native would
turn that JavaScript into your native
code it does not really turn that into a
native code if you take a look at under
the hood but let's just keep that
abstracted and let's just as you that
react native somehow does some magic and
turn your JavaScript code into native
code and basically once you're done with
that your application actually wants
native so it's not running into a
browser or something which some hybrid
application frameworks like ionic to
react native actually runs native code
on your device plus it's super fast to
do it's super easy to learn you just
have to learn JavaScript if you have
already launched our script or you have
been working with JavaScript for some
time then you're good to go basically
for Android and iOS now the downsides of
react native is that basically you
cannot read almost every app with it I
usually prefer to go with react native
for smaller and quicker apps and
sometimes some big apps as well but
react native I guess is not suitable for
developing high end performance things
like games or something like that
because in that case native is still the
best the react native still compiles to
native but I guess with native you have
a lot of gears in hand to tweak the
controls we're gonna discuss how to set
up react native environment and
basically get started working with react
native to get started with react native
we need to obviously set up its
environment and all that stuff first so
first things first how do we actually
set up reactivate it so if you go to the
official website you can see that we
have got a nice get started link here
alright the confusion starts here now
there are two sanctions sections you can
see Quick Start and building projects
with native code now most of the people
who dive into react native for the first
time get started with these this Quick
Start pen which is basically just a
couple of lines and you're good to go
now as good seems at least for me I
think this create react native app is
not the best choice because it runs on
xbox Island which I personally do not
really like because Expo kind of limits
you and a lot of things because react
native on its own is like you're writing
JavaScript plus you can do a lot of
tweaking and on that stuff with the
native code as well but when you use
something like Expo you get bundled
right so you are not allowed to move out
of a specific room so if you want to go
with this Expo one you can but I would
go with native code by building projects
with native code and once you do this
what you have to do is obviously go
ahead and
I've node installed on your computer now
if you do not know what node is then let
me just show you what do you actually
mean by let's say yeah just gotta go to
a directory let me just zoom in here a
little let's say I go to home directory
and let's just let's what we have in
here so say YouTube it is and then we go
with let's just remove this react native
directory for now and let's just create
react native again
alright so now all you need to do
basically is have node installed and
again you can do that by following
instructions here now make sure you
select your target as target OSS Android
for now because obviously iOS can only
be developed on a Mac which is kind of
which kind of sucks but it's okay we are
good with Android only right now so if
your Mac OS user then you can install
node with Bri you or basically there's a
video of mine which shows you exactly
how to set up latest version of node and
NPM on your system I'll just leave that
link in the description so if you want
to set up node or NPM you can watch that
alright you can skip this watchman tool
if you want it's not really required so
once you're done with this you need to
install the react native CLI so to do
that again you have to just do NPM
install react native CLI and make sure
you install it globally by writing the -
G flag and since I already have that
installed I guess it should not take me
a lot of time a lot of time so you can
see that it's just fetched local copy of
that thing right and yeah one more thing
what you want to do is make sure you run
your NPM around four point something
version this is the problem you're gonna
face
later on when you use your react native
applications that you cannot really run
npm on version safe right so this is why
i'm running version 4.6.1 because i'm
using react native to create code amps
bilap so that's why npm basically npm
version 5 is not really compatible with
react native the last time i checked so
if you face any problems and you find
out that your npm version is version 5
point something or above then what you
want to do is npm install g npm and a do
it version here right
in my case it's 4.6.1 alright with that
being said now once you have done that
you should have your react native CLI
onboard and after this what you want to
do is obviously have installed android
studio now you need android studio
jdk and all that stuff because remember
reactant 8 is actually developing native
apps for you so just go ahead and
download the JDK and how you do that is
basically see you accept the License
Agreement first and then select your
operating system or means Mac OSX 64 bit
and just download this and run it you
should be good to go once you do that
just go ahead and download the Android
studio as well once you do download
Android studio I already have that up
and running as well you would be
provided with android sdk sdk platforms
and all that stuff
you would also have a Android virtual
device do I do not really recommend you
can just directly you know work with
your real Android device if you have one
if you don't have one that's another
thing so you can't create an Android
virtual device which we will see later
on as we proceed alright so under studio
is pretty straightforward if you have if
you guys have ever worked with it I just
haven't downloaded and it will just
start downloading right on once you just
you just have to install it you do not
really need to use Abbot's to do
to work with react native just because I
know it studio brings all that STK stuff
together all right
once you have downloaded just install
Android studio and you can see that
building a react native app with native
code however requires Android 6
marshmallow SDK in particular so react
native right now may be uses Android 6
SDK I'm not sure because they're saying
it I believe they use that but sure
enough you can use another targeted SDK
later on in your application because hey
you remember react native is running
native code so if you're coming from an
Android development background you must
know there's a file called Android
manifest and will not create al and all
that stuff you're gonna find exact same
files in your react native project as
well so if you do not have any idea what
the heck these terms are don't worry
about that we'll gradually learn them
later on but for now I'll just remember
that your react native right now is
targeting this Android 6 platform and by
targeting that means that your app would
be most optimized developed for this
thing and for backward compatibility you
have to add some sort of code or
something forward compatibility for
forward compatibility as as well so yeah
so here we are and you do not need to
really do all of this stuff just make
sure you install this Android 6 our let
me just give me a second here alright so
you see something like this when you
launch Android studio right and what we
actually have to do here is basically
you have to go to like your Android
studio and you would probably see
something like a bunch of hello world
kind of stuff here don't worry about
that it's not really useful what you
just have to do is just go right here to
this SDK manager little boy this Android
with an arrow on his head just go to
Android SDK manager Android SDK SDK
platforms and make sure you install this
Android marshmallow and at 6:00 you see
I have installed that already
to stick on it and click ok it will
download that and install it for you
that's basically it what you have to do
or the SDK one and you can see that we
need something some else something else
as well like Google APs and what is to
give which we had already done Intel x86
atom 64 system image and all this stuff
and basically you would find all of that
stuff right here inside here SDK
platforms is here is to get tools you
can find that stuff here right you have
to install these SDK tools as well then
once you're done with this sdk tools
thing you see that you have installed
this 23 point 0.1 and stick your tools
and just go ahead select these 23 point
whatever what it will latest version is
it doesn't matter and click on ok right
once you do all of that stuff all you
have to do next is configure these
variables by adding them to your bash
profile and for the Windows guys what
you have to do is if you go right here
you have to add it to your path right so
how do you add it to your path well for
the Windows people you have to
right-click on your this PC icon then
you have to go to somewhere like
advanced settings of your computer then
you would see environment variables and
then basically add those stuff for Linux
and Mac OS users just copy the stuff and
mine tomorrow just copy the stuff and go
ahead inside your terminal right here
just opened your bash profile or no -
well
bash bash profile hit is right so just
open your bashful file provided file and
just copy and paste this stuff right
here which we see inside so you will
have set up your all those variables for
Windows guys again as a tool you just
have to go to system settings and
basically add environment variables just
google how to add environment variables
and you should be good to go right once
you're done with all of that stuff right
what you have to do is go to your
project in which you want to actually
write good of your Android application
and iOS application in my cases go down
YouTube react native and right here you
have to say react native in it and then
your project name let's just name it
hello world and hit enter now you can
see that it creates a kind of a
walkthrough kind of thing so you see
that it's installing all the required
packages it's it's using yarn right now
but you can make use of NPM as well they
they mostly work in a similar way or the
package store JSON file so anyway yeah
so let me just grab the Sun pick it
right here you can see that we just did
react native in it our project name then
you can actually do all of the stuff
later on it's not really required right
now I'll tell you how to do this this is
all cool right so what you have to do
right now first of all is this make sure
this thing right here goes well and if
it does not go well then go ahead and
repeat the steps make sure you have
added the environment variables
correctly when those guys you have to
add it to your path variables inside
your this PC settings Advanced Settings
environment variables and then selecting
path variables you can easily see how to
do that by selecting this way
those here see just like that open
system pain system security gene
settings advanced tab environment
variables click on new and just like
that right Mac and Linux guys I hope you
can do it yourself because you have been
working on with bash and all that stuff
at least I believe Linux people at least
work with that stuff all the time so you
just have to copy and paste this inside
your bash profile and this is bash RC
basically on a Linux system bash profile
on a Mac system and once you have done
that and still the error is there then
there might be some problem with
installation of your Android studio SDK
and all that stuff make sure to check
all of that as well
and if the still if still the error
persists then you can ask that and
commence and I'll be just happy to help
you so let me just really quickly wait
here for it to complete it might take a
little bit time for you for the first
time because in my case it might be
fetching a lot of stuff from the cache
itself but for you it would be
downloading all that stuff so you see
that I am looks like I am already done
alright you can see that it's set up on
my end and hopefully should be set up on
yours as well and basically that's it
for this video and in the next video and
we're just gonna show you a very basic
hello world with react native which is
basically just already prepared for us
we just need to run an emulator and fire
it up
/ through basic file system and how
react actually organizes its files so
that it's easier to work for you later
on with the application for the
structure and all that stuff so let's
get into it alright so coming to the
file structure off we have right here
for react native is that if we see
something like this if we start from the
top you would see that we have two
folders which is Android and iOS now
these are basically the only folders you
would spend most of your time in right
because Android consists of two files
which are used to build the application
for Android platform and similarly on
the similar basis iOS is used you can
see these all these X Cassatt files if
you are coming from an Xcode background
so these files would be similar to you
so these are basically the files for the
iOS stuff right and for Android you can
see that we inside the app we have
builder crater file as I told you
earlier on
then inside SRC we also have the
manifest file which is basically the
same thing as if you're working with
Android studio right so these are the
two folders which would be looking all
along this series so I'm just gonna skip
over them right now and coming to normal
duels obviously because it's running on
JavaScript we can have our additional
modules with us and which would be
installed inside the node modules folder
and once the app is compiled then all of
that stuff would be basically just
managed by react you do not need to
worry about that then come to the babel
RC file which is just the file
consisting of one line for now just sets
the preset to react native nothing
fancier here then this is buck config
file this is not really required because
this is there's a system called buck
build something used by Facebook but
we're not gonna make use of this so we
do not need really need to know what's
going on with this file right so same on
a similar basis this is flow config file
then we have the gate files so that
you can actually just check out your
project to a github repository as well
so these are files which would help you
then again watch one configuration file
nothing plans you're here then comes the
apt or cheers file right so after JS
file if you see here you would see
something familiar right now be when we
would run the application you would see
that basically the things you see here
are the ones which you see on the app so
you see that it kind of looks like HTML
but not really view text looks like they
are this is HTML but it looks like we
are making use of some native elements
right like the view container the text
container or all that stuff so we'd come
to that later on then we have the advert
JSON file which just consists of the
name and you know stuff like that
related to your application pretty
handful stuff so the next thing is
indexed or chairs and basically this is
the file which is boost which bootstraps
your application right so this is the
first file which react native enters so
yeah you can see that we are importing
the app from here the same file here and
putting it into index dot J's and we are
just registering the component with the
app right then our package dot JSON is
obviously the file which consists of all
the dependencies and all that's fancier
stuff so that's all for this video I
guess and file structure is quite simple
for react native not much of things
going on so that's all for this video
and in the next video I'm gonna show you
how we can run this dummy project on a
real Android device for now
in this tutorial I'm just gonna show you
how to set up your Android device
correctly so that your bills are
happening and basically you're just
ready to go and code so let's get
started alright so this would be a
helloworld tutorial so let's just go
ahead and create one so now if we take a
look inside the code what I want you to
do first of all before actually starting
off with the hello world just go to your
android folder and just go to this local
the properties file if this does not
exist
then create this file right once you
create this file I want Union I want you
to determine what operating system
you're running and hopefully you know
that I believe and if you do know then
just go ahead and choose one of the
lines which is according to your
operating system so right now I'm
running OS X so that's what I'm just
gonna keep this line and move the other
two right and just save this basically
this virus is telling the react native
where the SDK is located for Android
right and once you do that basically we
are good to go so now you can just go to
lab degeus and change this to hello
world with just some text and this is
again not an error because vs code is
just complaining that this should be in
a tight code file not a J's file not a
problem really but it's okay so there we
are and once you're done with that just
go ahead to your terminal and write
react native run Android and hit enter
now I have my personal Android device
connected right here if you can see this
one right so we can just wait for this
bill to complete and then I would
actually be able to run this application
on a real Android device which is the
same right here you can see I can move
this around with my finger without
actually touching the screen right so
here we are and let react native build
the application and meanwhile what I can
do is inside and
tab right here I can see react native
run iOS and simulator would be iPhone 8
plus now you cannot do this if you are
running anything other than Mac OS X
because I OS development unfortunately
can only be done on Apple devices so
once you do that you can see that I
already have my terminal my hip
simulator running with me so there we
are let's just wait for both of these to
complete now this this might take quite
some time for first time building but
subsequent builds would be faster right
this is because this just needs to set
up all that stuff first of all and then
later on it could be faster and if you
see right here this gets opened right
now what the heck is this well this is a
metro builder bundler and this opens for
Android right and what this means is
that whenever you change some files some
JavaScript files where your application
needs to inform let's just say your
phone or maybe your phone needs to
inform that yeah something is building
right so this is done by this thing so
you just need to keep this open in the
background and you can see the progress
of building bundling P device right now
on my Android device as well if you can
see that you can see that we get a
message of loading from localhost put
881 so yeah that's basically what's
happening right now and if we see iOS
bills well some sort of stuff is going
on here let's just not disturb this
thing and let's just get back to our
Android build stuff all right you can
see that our Android Android bundler is
100% done so let's just see what's up on
my screen
hey it's hello world from react native
so you can see this is a truly native
application running on your device on
your android phone right now coded in
JavaScript right and this is a real
Android device
actually real because I'm just mirroring
my phone on the Mac OS the iPhone build
seems to take some time but it's okay
let's just wait right to build okay so
it looks like we got it so we'd say this
build succeeded and it also install and
launch so let's just see how it's
looking like so you can see that it's
now our bundler is again bundling the
iOS app let's just wait for it to
complete loading all right you can see
that we get a nice little hello world in
the center of the screen on our iOS
device as well so if you take a look and
if I just bring this down you can see
that we are running the same piece of
code on two different operating systems
using react native that's the power of
react native
we're gonna discuss about how the hello
world program actually works and in
general how react native overall works
so let's get started so in this video
let's just see how the hello world which
we had coded earlier is actually working
alright so if we come to our Android
project right now as I said AB Dutchess
is the only point of entry right now
basically the point of entries indexed
or chase but you know it's indexed OCS
actually includes the app file here so
we can just say like that and we can
actually just get rid of this probes
right here and replace it something like
this I'm just gonna explain in a minute
what these props are not in a minute but
maybe in the next tutorial but we'll
just go through over what's happening
here so before starting this web series
I believe that you have at least the
basic knowledge of how es6 and stuff
like that actually is working because if
you do not know about that then it would
be kind of difficult for you to follow
along the series because react native
would mostly be using es6 all along so
yeah I guess you need to actually just
make sure you are up to date with the
es6 stuff all right with that being done
first of all what we are doing is we are
importing the main react framework and
the component from the react stuff right
and then we are importing this platform
which is basically just used to
differentiate between different kind of
platforms right so for example you can
see that instructions would be for
example for iOS would be shown this one
and for Android will be shown this one
so platform-specific work would be done
with the help of this library or a
module which we are importing from the
reactive module itself right next is
style sheet now style sheet is something
which would be used to actually create
and basically apply CSS to your react
native component and said CSS like CSS
because it's not really CSS right
obviously because your code boils don't
native code but it's
it looks like CSS but you would see that
it's mostly flexbox and not mostly its
react native who works on a flexbox
layout system right so you would be able
to use of make use of stuff like flex
one you know like flex crew and stuff
like that in your style sheets and apply
them later on to your views right now
text is you can say it's a kind of
component which would render your text
right so it's just used to display some
text on your application and view is the
container component you can think it off
like a box in which all of your other
components like text and you know
basically other components would go
could go in right so what the heck are
you actually seeing here if you ask me
well what this is is this part is known
as j6 now j6 and what it does is that it
allows you to write HTML inside of a
JavaScript if you have never seen this
it might look a bit episode to you that
how the heck are we actually writing
HTML net but if you're coming from a
react.js background or basically you
just know GS x then you should be able
to catch up real quick but for those of
you who do not have any idea
basically what DP or what we are doing
here essentially is that this app is a
component and basically everything is a
component in react.js as well as in
react native so app is a component whose
view looks like this and by view what I
mean is the template of that particular
component so component could have a
template it's logic which would be the
functions which would go here so you can
just go ahead and create my function
here and this would be kind of the logic
of some sort of function you would do
and then this render function is called
which basically just you know
gets the view template of the particular
component and displays it on the screen
so this is our very basic add component
which just renders simple hello world on
the screen and that bottom of the screen
we have is just the Styles where we have
a style sheet that creators used to
actually create a kind of a style sheet
which is kind of stuffed object again
whose key consists of the name of the
you know you can say a selector or
basically you can say the class name or
something like that because well how you
apply is like style as a prop name now
this is a prop which I was talking about
earlier equal to your whatever object
you want to style with right so we're
gonna come back to all of this later on
as you proceed but this is just a
high-level general overview of how this
hello world app works and if you are
following along if you have understood
this then it's great because we have
done quite some stuff and this and if
you understand everything it's awesome
if not then don't worry we're gonna
cover all of this bits and pieces later
on as well as we proceed with the
individual tutorials
we're gonna take a look at what props
are in react native and basically why
the heck would you need that and all
that stuff because you're gonna make use
of props all the time in your react
native application so it's just easy to
you know just understand it later
earlier and then you would be able to
relate a lot of stuff later on so if we
take a look inside our code right here
which is from the last tutorial you can
see that we are actually making use of
props right here so what props are
basically is that the they give extra
information to your components as I said
this text component or this view
component right here would have very
specific functions associated with it
right now we are making use of the
inbuilt components later on we can
create our own custom components as well
but for now let's just say I want to
display text with some southern-style
right so what I'm gonna do is make use
of the style property which is
associated with this component right
prop stands for property obviously if
you are not able to relate it to LA so
let's just say I would give you another
example let's just say you want to
display an image in your application so
what you're gonna do is right here image
and if I hit tab does it import it for
me
no not really going to import import the
image component here as well so once you
do that what happens now is that now you
have an image right here you go okay
sounds good but what the heck does this
image it can do well you need to give it
additional information like the source
of the image you want to load right so
the source of this image would be and
I'm just I'm just gonna explain what the
syntax here is would be let's just say
URI would be something like my awesome
side coms - my awesome image dot PNG
something like that so now you're
telling this component right here to
have this property which gives it some
formation right and what the heck the
syntax is is basically this comes from
the JSX so if you want to have a
variable kind of a variable think inside
your attribute value in GSX
what you have to do is just include that
inside the curly braces if you do
something like this this would be static
value right right now since you're
making use of an object so I'm inserting
an object here which contains all this
stuff so I need to make use of this at
this curly braces here you can also do
something like this like constant image
info and then do it like this and then
pass in your image info here it's one on
the same thing but because I'm just
writing this object right here directly
you can do it separately as well so
again this style style stored welcome I
can basically just get this stuff here
just put it right here and there we go
it's one on the same thing right
so you do not need to really you know
just wonder around what this curly brace
mean it's the style you have a variable
placeholder right here for the value or
basically dynamic something dynamic is
coming inside JSX
right so that's basically it for the
prop section and basically if you are
creating your own components then you
would be able to define what kind of
props you want to receive and what
happens with your component and all that
stuff later on would come to us when you
when we would discuss our own custom
components but for now you would have to
query the documentation to see what
components you have for what props you
have for a given component right so if
you see we could actually can we get the
list of components from here I'm not
sure so okay it does not let me go more
backwards in the code so I guess not so
yeah you could just refer the
documentation otherwise you can just
follow along and just see what kind of
props I'm making use of and you should
be good
started with state in react native
alright so if we take a look inside
the code you would see that actually I
have the app already running on my real
device and you could use an emulator as
well I'm just using my real device here
so it does not really matter
okay so what's we learned about props in
the last video was that properties are
basically these things which are
associated with your components and
which could be passed down into
something known as your child components
which would come to later on right but
what state means every component has a
particular state right so what that
means is that if you change the state of
your component and my state I mean a
particular object in that component
react would smartly check what stuff was
changed in that particular state and
which stuff your component needs to be
updated off okay so let's just break
this into code example right so first of
all let me just get rid of all of this
stuff which is not really required and
clean it up a little bit so that it's
easier for you to see right so we can
just keep style sheet I guess get rid of
this then text we can just get rid of
the image as well here for now
there we are alright so now what I need
to do is just create a constructor here
constructor and I believe you know what
this constructor is it's just es6
right now what I'm going to do is save
this but state is a black object right
so this state is actually a really
special kind of object it's not just a
regular check right now it's monitored
by react in the background and whenever
I call let's just say this dot said
state right if there's something
appreciable to be changed then this
render method would be called again
right so if I use my state variable
somewhere in the inside the render
method
and the said state is called which
changes by state variable then what
happens is that this component is
rear-ended after detecting what
particular things are changed right so
let's just see a quick example of that
so what I'm gonna do here is let's just
say okay what I'm gonna do is basically
let's just say I'm gonna get rid of this
star welcome or basically what we can do
is just include this as an array and I
can say that this is like custom styles
something like this dot custom styles
right so what happens now or instead of
legs this state custom styles right so
what's that what's what I'm doing here
is that applying style start welcome
which is this block of styles to my text
component right now and this thing as
well which I'm gonna develop which I'm
gonna write here really soon so don't
worry about what style does is it's just
an example to show what state does right
now so I'm gonna say this dot state dot
custom styles let's just say this is a
custom style and if you follow along you
could see that we can set an opacity of
let's just say 0 right and what I can do
is let's just say I can create a set
interval here and I can say something
like every 1 second what I want to do is
do something like this at set state I'm
gonna say my custom styles is actually
consisting of opacity of 1 right so what
that means is that every second I'm
changing something in my main state of
the component right so the react react
application should technically rerender
my component with the updated Styles
right ok so let's just go to device and
if I just shake my device here
I'm hit on reload here you would see
that the development server don't okay
let's just try to run the bundle again
let's see what's happening here so it
saves me this is not allowed before
super ok cool so we can just call super
here and we should be good to go I
believe let's just go back to the
terminal and see if it's building or not
alright so you can see that we have 100%
of the build and now if I just take one
more time shake my device here hit
reload you would see that it does not
blink because because opacity is not
really the style which you can apply on
a text field right so let's just change
this from color from varsity to color
and let's just say I just want to make
this color of let's just be queen and
let's just say I just give it a default
color of blue here so it will start with
blue and it will just toggle between red
green red green red green and so on and
so forth let's try one more time here I
go
shake it reload it starts with Red Queen
then it's always green
okay because yeah obviously you is not
turning it back to red right so looking
to say here that if this dot state dot
custom style start color is red then
turn it to green
otherwise don't it do good just like
that one more time let's just shake our
device and you can see how fast these
bills are because you're not really from
building the whole application itself
that's what react native does behind the
scene for you so now you can see that we
have red green red cream toggling colors
with us and basically that is possible
because of the state so you see that we
do not have any sort of logic which
updates which rear Enders this component
when the state changes right so react
does it automatically on its end that's
basically how state works and mostly in
bigger application what we that is
something known as Redux but it's way
too early for things like Redux to be
discussed but right now states would be
good for us to go and basically would
help us to manage the state the actual
state of the component how the component
remembers stuff we're gonna take a look
at what the style sheets are react
native and basically this create a
little application as well surrounding
around that concept
so let's it start ok so now you can see
that on the Left I have my device open
again and on the right we can see the
code which is which was responsible in
the last tutorial for this toggling of
this color so let's just get rid of all
of this stuff and let's just see what
these style sheets are ok so what's the
deal with them is and I mean let me just
actually just change it to tabs yep all
right so what's happening here is that
basically you create some sort of styles
in react just like you do on the web and
react native converts them into native
properties associated with those
particular elements right so for example
you can position of you somewhere you
can basically change the properties like
color of
texts its opacity and background and
stuff like that so what we have right
now is which react native what's the
thing is that all the layouts would be
actually flexbox based right so what
that means is that every view container
here every element is basically would
follow the flexbox system which comes
from the web on with CSS right so by
that what I mean is that all these
elements have by default a display flex
property associated with them and you
cannot actually change it
reactors works on flex box system so
what we can do is basically right here
we can try to create a very simple kind
of like an interface so what that would
be is let us say half the screen would
be let's say red half to be green right
so this is our container let me just go
ahead and create another view here let
me just say that I have Styles dot half
with this right and that in this view
and what I'm gonna do is just lift leave
this container with Flex of 1 which
means this space if I get all the space
if it's the only child just if I content
link let me just get rid of these first
and let me just get rid of this as well
all right so what I'm gonna do now is
say let's say half as flicks off fund
and then background color
or let's say red how this was named is
half one rate let's just get a name this
half - I'm gonna do a similar thing to
this we're gonna do here see half right
so what's the thing here and again by
default on the web flex box follows a
flex direction of row right but on react
native it follows by
for the flex direction of Gollum so now
if I just go back to my device shake it
a little here just reloaded you should
see that we get a red and a blue column
here just reposition this right here so
you see that our half one is red and our
half Dube is blue and as you can see
that by default it follows a flex
direction of column instead of row so if
you want the row then you can specify
the here flex direction and then grow
and it's safe and actually I can just
enable something known as hot
freeloading here so you should be able
to see changes without me shaking that
device so if I just remove the statement
again it's safe you can see that hot
reloading at its best I can just do it
automatically right so that's the thing
okay now let this is go ahead and create
some complex layouts right so what we
can do now and basically if you just
know how to play around with flex box
it's kind of easy to do so we can say
like style start half to one and we can
just say a similar thing on half to two
and four here I can say half to one it
has the same flex up one again and
background color of less you see Queen
it's also flex of one and background
color is yellow right let me just get a
comma here and now if you go ahead and
see you can see that okay
it kind of is not looking like it should
and the reason for that is because what
we want basically is that yeah it's
actually working fine because as I said
flex box works in the Flex direction of
column
all we can do is change this half do
right here do flex direction of row
right you can see that actually would we
can just dismiss that you can see that
now we have got a bigger element and
then two smaller elements in their way
now again it really depends on how much
you know about flexbox layouts right so
you can just practice them on the web
and that would be kind of similar thing
on the on here as well so here's a way
to actually displayed in do is to one
ratio so Green takes sixty six point six
six percent of the width and this yellow
takes thirty three point three three and
there we are
so basically now you can just go ahead
and include some sort of text with them
as well so this is two one right and you
can do a similar thing here with saying
this was - - under cells one right so
now if we take a look you see that it's
kind of ugly
so what we can do is just apply a style
of let's say style stop text here to
every text element and we can customize
them thereafter just like that
so we can say color is white then this
is a font size versus a turkey like that
and one more thing what I want to do
here is say that these half ones and
half tools right here have a justified
content of center and again if you can
observe that these JavaScript values
follows camel casing right so what
happens here is that if the CSS property
was like this then you remove the - and
you make the next letters first word
capital first letter next words first
largely so here we are justify content
center-aligned
items Center as well so this would the
center the text inside the block
similarly we can do this to do one and
do two and again this would when you
make them equal width here and there
looks exchanges from yellow to let's
just say um black so that the text is
visible because here I can see it on my
device straight away that it was
invisible so I knew so here we are
and now if I take a look you can see
that we got a Tech Center and all that
great stuff right so okay one more thing
let's see we can see that half to one
and half to do are sharing a lot of
common stuff by it apart from the
background color they are actually same
so what we can do is this we can make
something like half DX as a class
actually I can just apply all that
common stuff right here because it's a
good practice as well as well as it will
just make the code much cleaner and
easier to read I can just get rid of
this from that color right so now what I
want to do is basically apply have 2x to
pull up these elements so how would I do
that well to do that what I'm gonna do
is instead of supplying this just an
object I'll supply this an array of
objects and they would be applied in the
order in which you supply them so I'm
gonna supply it half to X right here I'm
gonna say styles got half to X and
similarly to our here style start have
2x and right now it does not really
matter because the property is to do not
you know overlap each other so the
precedence does not really matter here
now you can see that our code looks much
more cleaner and less than the previous
one and we can just apply multiple style
sheets to our elements
so yeah that's basically it and you can
basically supply any object you want
here you can just associate it Sociedad
up check with your state as well and
then you would update that variable your
render function would be called and your
CSS applied styles would be updated as
well to that element I'm just gonna show
you how to work with text input and
react native and basically just allows
you to get input from the user and
you're gonna make use of text but all
the way because you know forms are
almost everywhere in every application
so for example if you want to create a
form to asks about users information or
maybe like you're creating some sort of
game or something that you want users
name and you know the cases are endless
so let's just take a look at how to
actually write a very basic text input
code so right now you can see that I
have with me the previous code the codes
from the previous tutorial so let's just
get rid of all of this right and there's
a scare of get rid of this one as well
except for this container one right so
now what I want to do is inside this
view why the heck
there we are okay so now what I want to
do is basically inside this view I'm
going to write text input right here and
I can just import it from text input
just like that I'm gonna say something
like that right
so you can see that I immediately get a
text input so when I click on that you
can see that I can actually type stuff
around right so since this is an actual
device so I can just create it from my
end as well all right so what we want
however is you can actually customize it
with the various properties and methods
associated with it so if we take a look
add those you can see right here in the
documentation if you just open this and
go a little down you can see all the
properties on the props associated with
it so you can see that we have got a
bunch of stuff like editable and maximum
length number of lines on blur on change
so if we can do is basically target
something like unchanged X so you can
see that it's definition is called back
is called when text inputs change and
the difference between on change call
back that is calm and takes two inputs
text changes and this is that this on
change when it would be called then it
would not pass the updated text to your
function right so that's the basic only
difference so if you just want to listen
to if the text has changed then use this
one and if you want to get that text as
well along with that so you see you can
use this one so let's just go ahead and
implement this on change text and how we
do that is simply doing like unchanged
text and again as I told you in JSX
you have to use this curly braces so
that you are actually including dynamic
content here right so I'm gonna say this
dot handle change text right and again a
couple of things here what I'm gonna do
is basically find this
another reason for this is because we
bind a function whenever you know if you
want to use some sort of things which
are actually associated with this class
in this function for example let's just
say you want to access state in this
function handle change takes so you can
access this state only when this of this
particular this in this particular
function points to this class and
basically this is how JavaScript works
so I assume that you know a little bit
about it it's it's kind of on the
advanced side of JavaScript but it's
okay I guess you should know this so
this if points to this class then only
you can access the state obviously that
makes sense because state is a property
of this class right here but what
happens is that methods like these when
called from props do not necessarily
have the value of this associated with
this particular class because the
context of this is actually set in to
set to whatever function that is being
called whatever the calling function
wherever the calling function belongs
right so let me just give you a quick
recap of this so for example if you have
let's say an object let's just say this
is an object let me just comment this
whole thing or let's just leave it like
that only so if I have like functioned
by function and basically not like that
function and then you do like console
dot log this right so when you do like X
dot function then this points to this
particular object right but when you do
like something like if you have this
function outside
like that when you do like function to
then this actually points to the window
global inside if you're working with
with obviously right so what I wanted to
say here is that the context of this
right here this right here could change
whenever depending upon how this on
change text is called right so to avoid
that what we do is we just bind this
function we just force this function to
actually follow the dis of this class
only all the time right so let's just
get rid of or just get rid of this thing
and you only need to bind this if you
want to actually access something from
this class if there's no use then you
can just remove this line so what I'm
gonna do here is just say this dot set
state and again I need this I need to
use the spine because I'm using set
state which would only be available if I
am pointing to this particular class so
I'm gonna first of all let me just say
this this is value is empty I can say
here and I believe it's not really value
but because if you set the value of text
default value I believe it was yep so
yeah if you set up a value of additive
of a text input then you would not be
able to change it so you need to set
default values so this dot state dot
value now we're going to say and it me
something like that and basically right
here we can say value is and actually we
can just get the new text here now we're
going to say new text right similar on a
similar note we can say you are writing
this top state dot value something like
that where you have to actually reflect
the change as you are writing it so let
me just reload it right here and okay so
the application has stopped let's just
see why let's just go to our module
bundler let me just try to run it one
more time
Oh obviously because you cannot have
Dexter's floating like that right so now
I feel reloaded one more time you can
see that you are writing edit me is what
I get here and now if I try to did it
like remove it you can see that it
updates with me right so whatever I'm
writing here it's good it gets reflected
into the state and what the heck
okay so react native run on red might
have just reinstall the app so again if
you can see it's basically the same
thing right so now what you can do
basically as a task is that create a
basic layout of login right so how would
you do that I can just give you a little
bit of you know a starter so what you
can do is basically say something like
username right and you can actually
enter this whole thing in a view as well
password right and I'll just leave that
button bar to you so I'm gonna say this
is container flex one a handful X
Direction is obviously column so we can
just see justify contents enter and you
can see it gets us right there and I can
just say padding of 20 as well
so that we get a little bit of distance
right so now you can see that we have
got a little nice-looking layout I
believe and there's a problem again
because you cannot have like username
and password reflecting the same thing
so use the name and basically you can
just keep it in a state or you can just
you know get it when you tap on that
button as well it's kind of useful for
example if you're creating an
application where you want the user to
enter pin and as the user types 1 2 3 4
digits are with you and you can just
basically verify it so there you have to
just constantly keep your UI and your
model in sync but here I guess you can
just omit that but anyways so how do you
change stakes and yeah basically I can
guess we can just get rid of the state
here right and basically this one as
well new text we can just console here
and not really let's just say how do
user name changes so for example here
you
you're gonna take a look at something
known as uncontrolled hand control
components and what's basically the
difference between them so let's get
into it
alright so here we are with our little
dirty applications in the last video and
let's us first of all get rid of these
methods right here and this one as well
there we are there we go and it's safe
alright so so far so good now the thing
is if you take a look at the last video
what we did is that we have to retrieve
value of this text input somehow right
so what we did first of all is just
assigned a state variable to its value
and unchanged text we just updated that
state variable so that we get the value
all the time so the UI and the reactions
code react native code is always in sync
right so that's a way and the way is you
just get this input value whenever you
want to for example like on click of a
button or you know some action or
whatever so it's a specific event right
so for example if we if I create a
button right here
so say this button has a title of hello
to save this just include this button
here as well so you can see that we get
a nice little hello here and what I want
to do basically is that when it's
pressed this dot button pressed let's
just assign this dot button press this
button first don't find this right and
we can just say button pressed it's a
method here so what I want to do is
basically get username and password
values right so one way is to just like
we did earlier but I'll just first of
all have explore the other way which is
like constant username they're getting
that username value and password getting
the password
before that what I want to do show you
is something known as shake it here
debug Jace remotely so what it does when
you click on it it will open Chrome
inside your Chrome browser of actually a
react native debugger inside your Chrome
browser and you would be pretty much
able to access your JavaScript right
here so what we can do is basically say
something like reference we want to riff
for this input field right so what I
want to do is say something like a riff
and then these curly braces input and
I'm gonna say this dot user name is
input all right what the heck happened
here well this is basically kind of like
doing like ID is username in HTML right
pretty much you have done this thing so
now you can access this input through
this dot username right so I'm just
gonna get rid of this and say a similar
thing to this password I'm just putting
an underscore here because I don't want
to just randomly by mistake use another
variable name user name and they said
it's property overwrite its property so
it's it's just like it's kind of private
but it's not but anyways so what I want
to do now is just basically say console
dot log they start username this dot
password let's just see what this has
gotten for us and basically before that
what I want to do is just nothing okay
so let's just save this and type
something type something and hit hello
here right and you can see right here if
i zoom in a little we get username and
password here so if I could like this
property last native text you see that
we get
the actual text f G we see which is in
username right and on similar basis we
can get last native text on this right
so this is like kind of loading your
value on demand so I can see username as
this that user name dot last natives Tex
if I spell it right yep I've got some
password is this dot password dot last
native text I can just see username
password just like that just get rid of
this as well it's safe and it's a you
again because react native is stolen and
here we are so now if I enter SFU and
ffff hello because I'm not sure why I
did that
so f fu is username and F F F is
password right now this is a one-way now
this thing the width I have done it
right now is called uncontrolled
uncontrolled component and basically
it's not really uncontrolled component
in react native this control that
uncontrolled analogy is I've just stolen
it from react.js because in react cheese
and this is the concept right so
uncontrolled components are like this so
Android is managing its value and it's
giving you to whenever you want to
access it all right you do not have
access to it all the time for to make it
a controlled component what you need to
do is first of all we no longer need
this reference and what we can do is
just say default value of this dot state
dot username and I can say like on
change text is text and I can say this
dot set State username is text how
similar basis we can do this thing have
this one as well password
password as text there we are I can just
initialize the state with a blank object
if you wish or yeah that should be good
I guess right so now what I want to do
is get rid of these two ones as well so
now I always have access to this
username and this store password
irrespective if I press the button or
not so we always have access to username
and password because react is now
managing those values instead of letting
the host platform in this case Android
to manage it right if I had same now and
if I just entered something like this
and hit hello you can see that we get
undefined because this dot stayed on
username not username like that and they
stopped state dot password let's just
try one more time hello and I can see
that we get just like before but this
time react is managing so this is a
controlled component now the thing is
that you react actually recommends you d
always but really always use control but
in most of the cases use control
components that's okay to use controlled
components but the thing is that if you
do not really need to interact with
these components a lot what I believe is
that you are kind of like you know
updating state at every keystroke so it
might not really hurt performance that
much but I guess you could just go ahead
with an uncontrolled approach if you're
not really interacting with the
component at all so you can do that
otherwise it's equally good if you're
just going a controlled way as well
basically just having this controlled as
a control component gives you a lot more
power than uncontrolled one we're gonna
take to look at how to create our own
calculator yes you heard that right
and react native from the very scratch
so let's start off by creating some
applications in react because it's kind
of monotone us to just go through over
everything in react like thousands of
components and how everything works and
then at the end of the series you would
be like what the hell am I supposed to
do with all that stuff so I've decided
to break this down into little
applications built with react native
let's start with one calculator and
we're gonna see how we go along with
that so let's get into it so you can see
that right now I have my calculator open
now obviously we are not going to make
such a UI and functionality-wise
application like not gonna do this
animation kind of stuff and like all
that stuff right now in react native
because it's kind of like that wants to
do but we're gonna come to that as we go
along in the series so you can see right
here what we need is first of all a
place to actually show the stuff user
wants to do then here would be a result
and then right here we have our buttons
plus the operational buttons right so
let's just assign a little bit of UI for
this in this video so what we're gonna
do is first of all define let's say
style start resolve here which should
contain our result just like that
then what we want is view style as
Styles dot I'm not really result but our
or you can say that it's result it's
just what the result of what user is
typing and then we can say calculation
here right and then what we want is view
style Styles down buttons and like that
I'm gonna say that this is view style
style start let's say numbers
and on the right what we have is style
start operations right so that basically
is the whole complete layout which we're
going to need the parent layout at least
so let's just now use styles and yeah we
can use actually you would be thinking
that what the heck is the difference
between actually style sheets start
create and just using a regular
JavaScript object well the thing is that
you should always use style sheet not
create because when you don't use it and
react cannot actually validate your keys
and all that stuff and basically this
kind of like some sort of optimization
as well which reactors under the hood so
in short it does not hurt to actually
use style sheet or create all the time
when you're creating styles so just
stick with that so with tapping down
let's just create some Styles now now
for the container part what we need it's
just a flex one so that it gives us full
screen right now then for the result
moving in right now it's less to see I
give it a flex of one right I give it a
so say background color of red for now
so that it's visible to us then for
calculation pad I'm gonna give it a flex
off or let me just give it a flex of two
here
flicks off one here right and I'm just
gonna make it background color of green
right then for this part for buttons
what I want first of all is basically
like I want to display these buttons in
a column right so what I'm gonna do here
is say flex direction as column or
actually in row I want to display this
in group right because by default
react.js displays everything in columns
so I want to display in in a row has two
elements so there we are then for the
next part what we have is numbers
numbers go right here I'm just gonna say
this has a background color of let's say
yellow for now again so that it's just
visible nothing to do with original
application which we would be developing
an operations would be bagging color off
let's just say how many colors are there
versus a black for now right and let's
just give them a flex property as well
and for the buttons what we can say is
this flex grow one so that it just
occupies all the remaining space so
numbers could be flicks of let's say d3
I'm not really sure we have to play
around numbers here and I can give it a
flex of one here so there we are and now
if we take a look at what we have
actually done so to do that let's just
go back to terminal and do a react
native run Android here so react would
fire the application real quick and by
the time we are waiting for that to
happen let's just see how we're gonna
create these numbers so to create them
again we will need to have one two three
four separate views inside our numbers
which would contain rows of elements
right because we cannot have grid
layouts and all that fancy stuff and
react yet because it just supports a
single display and holy crap we use not
imported that is so cool
let's just import that and here we are
well it kind of looks bad
because the result is stupid right so
what we can do instead is instead of
using flex flow here let's just say I
have a flex off we have 2 plus 1 3 and 7
so it takes 70% width of the screen
right it takes 20% and it takes 10%
height not the weight sorry
so there we are with a very basically
out for our calculator
we're gonna take a look at how we can
actually go along and build the
internals of our parent layouts and
let's get into it really quick so um we
can just create some buttons here by as
I said in the last video by creating
rows of buttons so I'm gonna say style
start row here right so this would be
our rows and we're gonna need one two
three four four rows right here so we're
gonna say you one two three four just
like that and for each row we're gonna
need a button it's so button title and
I'm just gonna give it a title off let's
just say zero for now to every rule
just like that so we're gonna have one
two three we're gonna have one two three
and we're gonna have one two three and
you're gonna have one two three
there we are right and button is not
defined very well let's just import this
guy and there we are okay so what the
heck is this so what we want to do
actually is display these elements
inside a row right so I'm gonna say
right here as flex direction of row as
simple as that so you can see we get
these elements now but what's the deal
with them is that we want these rows to
be equal in height all of them and
occupy all the space so there we are
that's a start and what we can say is if
I'm not wrong just if I content we'll
have to take a look at this Center
aligned items
stretch stre TCH or it could be other
way around as well I'm not really sure
yes it is I believe
um okay so we have just a Content value
of let's just okay give it a central the
I believe there used to be a stretch so
anyways let's say this is spaced around
instead so that we get nice little buns
buttons like that
okay so now we have buttons so what we
want to do is basically add these
operational buttons as well so to do
that again we're gonna make use of and
actually we can just kind of make use of
the buttons here directly because these
buttons actually are one single row one
two one what the heck
one two give me a second here all right
one two three four there we are
and if we save this take a look just
like that again but style start
operation right so what we're gonna do
here is say that it's flex Direction is
obviously column but I want justify
content as based around here as well so
that we get something like that right so
actually I guess we should just take a
look at the docs to see what justify
content here accepts and you can see
that it accepts flex start flex and
center space between space around and
space evenly alright so how about if I
want to stretch it line items stretch
stre TCH I'm not sure I guess it used to
be somewhere but it's okay
stretch okay so alright anyways so here
we are
but that kind of looks funny Louis's
reverted back to Center at least for now
so here we are with the basic layout we
want in here is for the result part text
style styles dot result text right we
can say just basically like one to one
just like that and for calculation
always the same eleven times eleven here
and for calculation part what we're
gonna do is say a similar thing style
styles dot calculation text and again we
are doing all of this in a single file
but don't worry about that we're gonna
take a look we're gonna learn how to
split reaction react native code into
multiple modules because that's
essentially what you're gonna do all the
time because that's a best practice
actually just modularizing your code so
calculation takes what I want to do with
this is font size as 20 color that's
white and similarly to not really
calculation text I believe to resolve
text that's what I wanted
so result text here we are for
calculation takes what I want to do is
font size that's 14 and color as white
too
and there we are
so let's just increase this a little bit
more 30 Alice's bracket 24
all right so now we just want you to
central and that stuff so I'm just gonna
say it was sold right here if you see
just if I content on flex and just if I
contended I guess when you're working
with the Flex direction of column it's
kind of like it always confuses me it's
kind of like justifies along the y-axis
let's see Center aligned items flex and
yeah so it was complete guess rates and
just worked out just fine so we're gonna
need a similar one on our calculation
pad as well so there we are here we go
so this is the basic layout of our
calculator right now I know we need to
expand these buttons we're gonna take a
look at that in the next videos and we
need to change this content as well all
along all these buttons and all these
numbers should be right
and let's just make a little bit more
usable and customizable
okay so right now you can see that we
have these tiny little ugly buttons
right here with us so let's just make
them full width and height and do that
actually what we have to do is not use
this button but use something else let's
just say touchable opacity and what this
is is basically just like a button but
it just responds to your touch nicely so
I can just say that this is something
like that and if I just change it for
one row right now there we are
let's save it okay we just need button
for now so yeah touchable opacity needs
you to add a text node so we'll need to
change it here as well so now we can see
right here is that if I touch on this
kind of response if you can see so let's
say this is dialog button right here
with us so here we are
right and right here if I just go ahead
and say button
pals flex one align items
stretch line self as stretch as well and
this should be obviously stains right so
we can see now that the statue below
Vasa T thing responds even if I tap
right here right instead of on that zero
so that means our button is kind of
working for now so what we can say is
just instead is just make it like just
if I content center and a line items
Center because we would be any real
listening to the touchable opacity right
here instead so let's just see you can
see that it would get messy really
quickly right here if we continue to
develop code like this so what I'm gonna
do is actually develop this whole button
section separately so let's just say I
do something like for let I equal zero
high as less than three I plus plus
which is the number of one two three
four let's just make it for number of
rows for let I equal four let J equals
zero J is less than three J plus plus
right for now if we can do let's just
say that to let two elements is
something like that or we can just say
something like view or actually let's
just keep in an empty array so what we
can do right here let's just say lit row
is also an empty array and right here
what I'm gonna say is add row dot push
touchable opacity and basically this
block of code right here I'm just gonna
copy this and let's just change it to I
or a rather I plus one right and here
I'm gonna say elements dot push and what
I want to push is a view style of style
start row with the our row in it and
here we go so I hope it makes sense I
can just name it rows so that it makes
more sense right so we have our all that
stuff now so right now what I can just
basically do is go ahead and delete all
of this and just say and actually till
here and just say rows right if I hit
save you can see that we get it right
but it kind of is not really what we
want so it would be kind of like this so
you can see the that we get one two
three two three four three four five or
the hell okay let's see so you might
want to just debug this stuff later on
so I'm just gonna assume that I got
numbers in the right place I'll just
take a look at why they are not in the
right place it's it's somewhere in this
logic so you can just figure it out
yourself so what I want instead right
now is to just basically show you can
see that all of these buttons now
respond to the touch so we can say that
I can give it a property of like style
start button text right and I can just
go ahead and create this as well and say
that it's as a four
size of let's say 25 maybe or let us say
30 right so here we are with our buttons
right here for the calculator and
similarly what we can do for our
operations is a similar thing right here
so actually let's just fix it right here
quickly actually to fix this what we can
do is just say let nums is let's see 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and actually for the last
row we had to actually walk out of the
loop because last row is not really you
know numbers all numbers so it's kind of
like I'm not sure there's 0 in middle
and there's an equal to a belief at the
end but again I'm not really sure so
let's just keep it 0 0 and equal to 1
now
I'll just see in the calculator later on
so now I can just say here as nums of I
and J right and we get our correct
output now so that is one way and
similarly what we can do is for the
operations we can name them like plus
minus multiply divide 1 2 3 4 right so
what I'm gonna do is now let's just say
I copy this well actually we do not need
to copy it at all we can just say let k
equal to 0 and actually we can just make
use of I again because this is scoped
inside the function
so I'm just gonna say I plus plus again
just like that so again let's just see
let ops something like this so I'm gonna
say ops dot push and then this whole
stuff right here which we had earlier
with the exception that again this is a
button in fact but this would be
operations and this could be the bet
index only that's not a problem so here
we are and let's just name this ops here
and operations of I should be sufficient
here and there we go so what we can do
here is instead of just applying the
button takes class what I can do is
apply another class style start white
well let's just say which is we'll just
mix it white right so there we are with
our basic calculator interface with the
buttons working kind of right at least
responding to the touch but the result
and the calculation power is still the
same so we're gonna take a look at that
in the next tutorial
so right now you can see that our
calculator interface kind of looks
complete
I believe the buttons are in place the
buttons buttons kind of respond a little
well as well and they are full
read/write so you can just click here
and we'll just respond right you can
click here and the four would respond so
if we just if you can just draw the
boundaries then you would be able to see
that these are actually enclosed inside
a boundary right okay so anyways first
of all let me just fix this that this
should be a dot right here right and
what we have for now is that too we have
to actually get the function get some
sort of function called whenever I click
on this button so let's just go ahead
and create this so I'm gonna say that
this is something like button pressed
right so I'm just gonna say that I would
just get the you know text of that
particular button let's just see so
right here what we can say is something
like when I click on this on on press I
believe so once you do that what I want
to do is just call this function right
here this dot button press with the
argument of Nam's
I and J rights effects go ahead and save
this and for this console dot log this
as well it's safe and if you just go
ahead and shake my device here a little
and enable and actually it's already
enabled so we should be able to see it
somewhere right here so you can see that
our app right here is enabled
so it's just bugging about that we
should add a key property so that kind
of fits well with react so I can just do
that on these warnings would go away so
it's not a problem right here so what we
can do now is tap a button so one two
three four five six seven eight nine
zero dot and equal to okay
everything is responding correctly right
so what we want to do is basically once
we tap on these particular buttons I
want to update this thing right so what
I want to do here is say for example
first of all let me just get the view
right here which is responsible for this
and this is our this one this view right
so we want to do is basically set this
text to something like this dot state
dot let's just say result text because
again as I told you earlier if I change
my state variable somewhere then the
rendered render call would automatically
be called by react under the hood and it
will just update that particular thing
that particular component right so what
I can do right here is just say well
actually right here we can just keep the
result text blank it does not really
matter if it's smell it just does not
print that so what I'm gonna do is say
this that said State and I'm gonna say
result text is whatever the text was so
this dot State that result text plus our
update text right here which comes from
the button right so if I save this and
see like one two if I type close so you
can see that it reflects right here so
if I can just remove this and say 12.54
like that or five four nine something
like that now the problem with this is
obviously like if I type equal to then
it this writes that as well because it's
not really distinguishing right now
between the different kind of numbers
the only thing which is not a number
really right now here is this equal to
sign because a decimal can be you know
you can regard it as a number because it
is used with numbers so what you want to
do is add a little bit of validation
here so let's just add an equal to
validation so I'm just gonna say if text
is equal to an equal to well in that
case what we want is we want the actual
result so far which we have right here
so I'm just gonna say calculate result
here with this dot state dot result text
like that and actually we can just
return from here as well so I'm just
gonna say actually this should be this
right so I'm just gonna say calculate
result I'm just gonna say text here we
could have just access it here also but
yeah actually we can just do it right
here as well because we have access to
state and all the methods right so what
I'm gonna do is this a constant
text is my result text so we actually
need to now parse this text basically
like you have to broke break this text
into tokens and then perform all the
operations accordingly right so we're
gonna learn a little bit of tricks here
how computers actually do calculation so
that's basically how we are gonna going
to proceed so when you actually enter a
huge kind of like 3 plus 3 times 6 let's
just say raise to the power of 5 divided
by 2 plus 7 all that stuff so how a
computer would read that we'll just take
a look at that later on right when we
come to parsing this text right so that
could be an example for us so for now we
have fixed the equal to problem so you
can see that if I tap on equal to we do
not really get that equal to type and
again what we can do is just basically
not allow
a lot of zeroes in the front it's okay
to have zeroes like that but it's not
really okay to have zeros a lot of
zeroes in the front right and actually
what we need to do is add a back button
to the app as well and if you just take
a look inside the calculator will be
happy the delete button right here right
so what we have is 1 2 3 4 5 but how's
it working division multiplication minus
and plus plus minus multiplication
division 3 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 ok yes so
the rules are uneven the number of rules
are uneven in this case so now we can
just do that that should be easy for us
now we just have to add a let's say
let's just keep it D for now to delete
the text right and what we can do is
basically let it wait and what I want to
do now is if I type something and if I
press this D button right here
I want this text last element to be
deleted now this is a little bit of
tricky part here because right here we
are just generalizing it over the loop
so what we want to do instead is what we
can do is let me just think I guess we
could add each of them separately or
what we can do is just on press we can
pass in this function let's just say
this is operate actually we have to do
this startup right here and say
operations of I right so once we have
that what we can do is call this operate
function with the operation right I'm
just going to switch over this operation
because why the hell not
so I'm gonna see case D which is the
delete in our case what I want is that I
want to update the state again remember
this text right here is set with the set
state so what we have is let's say we
gonna text back again this dot state dot
result text which gives us this text
right here back to us right okay so what
I want to do now is actually just split
it so what you can do is this slice it
or just you know convert it into an
array and just do it in one line so I'm
just gonna do it in one line I split it
by every character then what I want to
do is just you know I'm actually we can
just do like text dot pop I guess it's
pop for back and unshifted for front so
we should be good so once we have done
that and actually we can say let text
here right here and takes job joint I'll
actually you could just run a slice call
here as well I don't really remember its
syntax otherwise I would have done that
but here we are simply with the split
call as well so now what we have is that
we want to update the state again so I'm
just gonna call and said state method
right here and say result text is again
equal to our text right here so if I hit
save now and if I just type something
like five by five head D you can see
that it gets erased and obviously that's
a bad example because all that just was
same so if I write one two three and
okay how it did it add a comma itself if
I delete it okay so here we are with our
first bug I'm not really sure how it did
that let's just reload it so if I add
like five five five five five five one
two three
how the hell did that come up here there
so if I do delete now so it saves me
this top state dot result text dot split
is not a function okay well why is it
not I believe we can just console dot
log R they start state dot result text
here every time so that we can just see
in the console what exactly is going on
so if I just reload it here
so if I write five five five numbers
like that and delete a lot of times so
we see that if I hit delete a lot of
times we get this thing so let's just
see it in the debugger so we have it
correctly wait a second what exactly is
happening here oh this is oh obviously
because this should go like here because
we cannot just split over an array again
right so if I do like this now and hit
delete yeah it makes sense now because
what I was doing here is that I was just
joining it but I'm I was not storing
this result anywhere right so it just it
was just a waste call so now you can
type basically anything like if I just
remove this dot and all that stuff I had
delete to delete that and here you are
it's just a basic implementation of the
typing feature for now
so here we are with our tutorial from
the last video I don't know what that
means but anyways so let's just proceed
where we have been doing so far so in
this video I just want to add support
for these plus minus and multiplication
buttons as well here and actually we can
see that we do not see the division
button and the reason for that is that
because we are omitting that and
actually we can just make it a little
bit more dynamic by just replacing this
for with or actually not this one this
for with the length of this but it does
not really matter because in calculators
we have very fixed operations available
with us especially in the one which we
are coding right now right so here we
are with our little division sign back
with us so now what we want to do is
just say that to when it's not D when
it's something like say plus so again I
just want to add it for now
to the screen because we're gonna
tokenize all our text later on so it
should be kind of easy for us so four
plus four minus four plus four minus and
for multiplication and for division what
I want is just at a basic validation
that our text is not really black
there's something at least to the left
of it right because that's what we
really want I don't want a person to
start with a plus sign because that does
not make sense
so what we can do is just say that if
state this dot state dot text is equal
to blank that means the user is directly
pressing these buttons which we do not
really want so I just want to say return
just like that and actually this should
be the case in our case D as well
because I
want the user to go beyond anything it
does not really make sense because movie
are doing essentially here if you take a
look inside the console you can see that
we get a blank element splitting on a
blank element right here you can see it
does not really make any sense
because it returns us a array of zero
length so when we split on that we pop
it we get nothing
so we get we joined it with nothing to
get a string back an empty string so
yeah it kind of works out itself but we
can actually just add this validation
right here so if it's not the case then
what we want to do actually just make it
shorten in a single line so that we can
just space save two lines whenever
necessary there we go so now if that's
not the case then what we want to have
is just this not set state as a result
text is this dot state dot result text
plus our operation right there
operation there we are so now if you
just see something like this plus this
minus this all right looks good now
another thing which I want to do is on
the button pressed if this thing is a
Cali is an equal to button so obviously
what I want to do is verify a little bit
of results a little bit of you know
things right here that first of all what
we can see is let me just say let me
just think about it what we can do is
just see if text dot or actually should
we just open eyes everything first let
me just think here so we can actually
ultimately we have two tokenize the text
anyway right so yeah I guess we should
dokkan eyes all the text first and then
proceed onwards and back
organizing what I mean is that if our
text is something like this so I can
just convert it into like three then
plus then three then star and then six
and then power and all that so they're
not really like that and it's just like
splitting character by character but
obviously like in the order of how it
should be organized so yeah I guess then
that's it for this video I believe
because in the next video I will be just
showing you how to organize all of this
stuff once you press calculator once you
actually press an equal to and obviously
we can fix this little bug right here
which just allows us to type for single
sign multiple times so what we can do
right here for now is just say if this
dot state of text is blank or this dot
state dot text dot let me see
split dot two let's see op equals two or
let's just say this is our character
right so what I want now is actually
test whether this is okay let's just
take it this way let me just clear stuff
so I'm just gonna get the last character
last character I'm just doing it so that
it's easier for you to see and follow
along so this gives us our last
character inside this field for example
a minus for now and what I want to do if
last character dot are actually not like
that
if operations dot index of the last
character is not equal to negative one
that means that means that last
character is in fact an operation so
what I want to do is just return because
I do not want to have two simultaneous
operations right so again what we can do
is just and actually not like that
because the operation could consist of
delete
character as well which we want to allow
so we can say is greater than zero right
so it omits our delete character and
actually let me just move it actually
let's just change this to a class
property instead so this start
operations there we go and I'm just
gonna say this start operations just
like that and move it into our
constructor just like that
all right so here we are now what I want
to do is actually I have already done
that so let us hit save and see if we
can see anything okay we get a split off
off undefined because it's not text it's
actually result text it's safe reload
plus operations was not different
because this is test dot operations
that's well that's embarrassing
anyway so let's just save it reload Wow
plus minus does not work very well
divide yep does not work and if I hit
delete it works perfectly fine so there
we are with a little bit of more
validation
so if we see right here inside the code
we had last time is that basically we
can just tap on some numbers and add
some operations as well and there's kind
of a little validation as we were going
along as we type all the stuff right so
we can actually delete them as well and
so on and so forth so what we want to do
now is as I said when we want to
calculate the result we want to parse
some text like this so if you just
consul not log this text first it's save
and let's just reload the app what the
heck does react
sometimes this you know does not reload
on savings
let me just manually reload here right
here by hitting reload
there we are so now if you just take a
look like if it's a say 21 + 54 and what
I'm gonna do is this press this equal to
right here let's see what we have inside
our console we have 21 + 250 volt right
so what we want to do now is basically
calculate this right so this is easy but
with operations like doing like times 8
minus this divided by this stuff like
this what we want to do is just follow a
kind of a standard or something now
there are I guess two standards I'm not
really sure what I know which off is
both mass which is like you have to
follow brackets first then off which is
not really a mathematical operator right
here inside our calculator then division
then multiplication then addition then
subtraction right so if there are
brackets you have to follow brackets
first and then sleeve this then division
and multiplication then addition and
subtraction right so we can do that so
to do that what we have is the first way
is basically there are two ways to
calculate this text right so what we
want to do is like let's see you might
want to have like split the character
with each character or maybe like I
trade over yeah splitting and I trading
over each of the character like that so
now you're gonna say if character is
your special character something like
this or you can just use an array and
test if their character is actually
included in that particular array then
you want to do something right so this
is a basic logical implementation of a
calculator but what we can do since we
are making use of react native and again
if you remember we are running
JavaScript right so we can cheat a
little here so what I'm gonna do instead
of this all this brainstorming and
finding out what stuff goes where and
aligning brackets and all that stuff
what we can do instead is make use of
our old good but in famous friend you
all so you all is actually used to
evaluate a value which is in a string
right so if I try to do you Val this
value right here eval 21 plus 55 let's
just say you see that we get this if I
do eval off like alert you see I get an
alert so eval is basically used to
evaluate a string as a JavaScript code
you should never use this on user input
but we're gonna use this on user input I
know right because of two reasons first
of all this is not a web application so
doing an email of alert is not going to
work really because we have not made our
app sophisticated enough to have
JavaScript functions executed inside our
Java running runtime environment right
so this could possess a problem if we
are kind of allowing anything to be
typed on the keyboard and then
evaluating it but since we are
restricting the user input
- only numbers basically and these signs
we can pretty much hope that they're not
able to type characters and you know
kind of self XSS them so yeah so it's I
guess safe to do so if I do like eval of
text so if I just console.log this as
well so yeah let me just comment this
out for first let's just freaking reload
this application enable library loading
there we go
basically actually I just flashed my
phone's Rob so that's why I guess I lost
some options here so it's Android 8.1
quite impressive it's it's actually a
resurrect remix ROM so if you have use
that it's kind of smooth til now works
awesome I'm really liking it so yeah and
if I do like 22 times 11 and then if I
just dismiss this equals 2 and then if a
good like console you see you see that
we get 22 times 11 is equal to 242 which
is in fact what JavaScript would tell
you anyway because that's the result
javascript calculated right so we want
to do is now basically update this value
and set our results right so what I'm
gonna do is say this dot set state and
I'm gonna say actually what do we call
this so we are kind of like saying that
this is calculation text so let's just
name it that calculation text and there
we go so what I'm gonna do right here is
again just initialize it for the stake
of sanity here and what I'm gonna do is
just say that I just want to set the
state with the heck are we this dot set
state calculation text is eval which is
evaluating
the input supplied by the user so if I
just dismiss this on 66 plus 55 equals
121 there we are
I'll actually disused dummy placeholder
with 121 only I believe so that's kind
of like and it's completely random right
you see that kind of works properly now
there could be a couple of problems here
for example if I just write plus and hit
equal to you see that we get unexpected
end of input
that's because we are trying to evaluate
something like evaluate to plus right so
this is the problem so obviously we do
not we cannot just leave everything on
eval so we need to do some sort of
validation at our end as well before
actually executing this function
so lets us get into the validation of
this text before we actually hit it and
if we see what we have right here is
that how we are calculating this is if
we press equal to we see that we call
this function but actually before
calling this function what I want to do
is just validate the text as well so to
alidade the text what I want to do is
just basically say something like this
dot do Ally date and this not calculate
result so what it will do basically is
that if this function returns false then
obviously the second condition for the
ant would not run so this returns true
then our this function would actually
run so we can safely just implement our
logic right here so again we're gonna
just get the text first with this dot
state dot result text right here all
right so now as of now what I can just
imagine as a case is that we just leave
an operator right there so if we do like
something like if text at sli's negative
one is equal to like plus or actually
like we can just switch over it as well
if you want we can actually just create
an array as well of these operators
there are so many ways to do it single
thing in JavaScript sometimes so take
stuff slice negative 1 is equal to or
actually what are you go to right here
KS plus K is minus K is multiplication
case division and we just return rate
turn false right and I just return true
otherwise all right there we go so now
what I want to do is just basically try
out it again and dismiss
and I say let me just try it from here
one day so if I just say equal to I get
when you do very well at a plus and then
right equal to okay the app does not
crash that seems right fifty five equal
to that's great so now if I try to do
like something like fifty five point and
then do equal to then also it does not
crash and mainly it does not because you
can see whenever eval would crash then
your so with your application you see
that actually in JavaScript numbers are
not really you know it does not really
[ __ ] about if you leave a decimal right
here so you see that X is still 55 right
here even if you like fifty five dot
right so it's not a big deal so yeah
that's basically that's how you would a
little bit of validation to your input
feed right here
so right now I have the regular
calculator opened up and right here is
the calculator which we have right so we
have a couple of things to do first of
all in the UI we need to update the
colors so let's just do that really
quickly so right here if we take a look
where we are setting these colors and
all is actually inside our stylesheet
right or basically the react styles so
what we want to do is just locate this
yellow green columns and update them
accordingly
so to update it the colors let's just do
a quick Google search right here say
calculator Android let's just leave this
we do not need here images and let's
just pick this one because we would be
able to just extract the colors just
like that and actually this is a little
trick I use if you did not know about it
well there you go then so here it is our
hex value for the yellow pad there we go
and our hex value for the buttons on the
right
could be just mmm let's see
instead of doing it a black versat there
we go so instead of doing it a color
white are we doing it correct numbers is
a view we need to actually style the
text right so actually not even the text
these numbers right so yeah let's just
do one thing let's just remove this
color from here and instead what we want
to do is actually style dot button text
which is what you want to modify and
give it a color of white and just like
that and once we do that you can see
that
basically our calculator already and
instead of this red and cream let's just
make it right and right hit save and
data let's just add a key property here
as well so that react doesn't complain
about it so for the key we can just give
it a key of nums of IJ only because
that's unique you have to keep your key
unique and kind of you know relatable as
well you can just throw in math dot
random sure you can but just it's just
preferable so if you have got some sort
of unique identifier in your data then
just go ahead and use that as the key
reactors needs it so that it has a track
of all the elements right and here we do
not have that
so just operations of I know this dot
operations what the heck am I even doing
this doll operations of I and there we
are so this looks much more like a
calculator and oh why the heck do we
have another one in here each child in
an array or a traitor should be a unique
key we are doing that aren't we or does
react expect us to do it here also so
let's just see there we are and I
believe we should be fine now
yep okay it's it looks like kind of
looks like a calculator not bad I
believe but the obvious problem right
here is that we start from here from
here the buttons 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and
the actual calculator starts from the
bottom so it's kind of like okay and
again we can just keep it del instead of
D
and that's actually just easy you have
to you can just make these as constants
as well at the top so that you don't
have to modify it everywhere if you
change it once right so I just prefer to
do that so you can do that as well but
here since it's a small program we can
just do a little bit of manual shifting
right so now if we just it's safe so it
looks much more like this right and we
can do some sort of operations as well
and holy crap so we have a white colored
text here so we need to update that as
well so very hard let's see let's see
let's see here we are calculation text
should be black and same for the result
text should be black hit save there we
are
22 plus 55 what it is hey it's 77 not
bad can your calculator do it 22 plus 55
well obviously this calculator does not
really require us to press equal to
write and actually pressing equal to mix
it and large so that's a task I want to
keep do you guys now detect how you
would create a functionality like this
so obviously you have to make use of
state variable here instead of like
doing calculations when you click on
equal to right so that you can update
and you know change the state on a
regular basis how the text changes right
also make trying to make this font size
a little bit bigger this one actually
and remove the bold it looks like it's
bolded so try to use a different font or
thinner font and make it enlarge as well
and you would basically good to go so
that's all for our react native
calculator applications if you liked it
and don't forget to subscribe and thank
you for watching